bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 ce
politique en ce mardi 24 février nous
allons principalement parler des
élections départementales mais tout
d'abord se conflit qui oppose Alexandra
Rosetti et Alexis Bettel l'ancien Meru
MP de voisins le bretonneu ne semble pas
digérer sa défaite de 15 voix au dernier
municipales face à son ancien adjointe
udi un recours a été déposé devant le
Conseil d'État et pour le rapporteur
public il pourrait être nécessaire de
retourner devant les électeurs c'est la
distribution tardive d'un tracts qui
motive cette analyse délibérée attendue
pour le 26 février qu'en pense Alexandra
Rosetti en tant elle se représenter en
cas de nouvelle élection sa réponse
c'est au micro de Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude et Élodie moine
en moins d'un an on a déjà un bilan
voilà des choses à présenter on a fait
des choses on sait où on va
donc je suis voilà après c'est la
démocratie voilà c'est vraiment
l'exercice de la démocratie
ce qui est embêtant c'est que dans ce
cas là le préfet suspend toutes les élus
sont délai et que la ville est gérée
pendant quelques semaines par un
administrateur temporaire donc il va pas
se passer grand chose à voisin pendant
on va dire tout le long du mois de mars
et probablement début avril voilà et
puis ce qui pourrait presque plutôt
m'inquiéter c'est l'abstention c'est à
dire que je pense que les gens ils en
ont marre de gens d'histoire voilà c'est
comment est-ce qu'ils vont réagir est-ce
qu'ils vont aller au bureau de vote pour
exprimer à nouveau un choix ou est-ce
qu'ils vont se dire bon il y en a marre
et voilà j'espère qu'ils se déplaceront
parce que c'est ça justement le jeu de
la démocratie
quant à Alexis le réfute l'idée d'un
combat personnel il ne souhaite pour
l'instant pas commenter cette décision
de justice avant que ne soit connue le
délibéré en attendant nous sommes allés
dans les rues de voisins de Bretonneux
afin de demander aux habitants si ils
étaient prêts à revoter et ce qu'ils
pensaient de l'idée
on reste derrière le la vie du Conseil
d'État voilà pour moi non parce que
parce qu'on n'a pas les résultats de de
l'enquête sur enquête et puis les gens
ont voté s'il s'avère que les 15 voix
c'est un peu frauduleux du fait
sans avoir respecté certaines choses
pourquoi pas si on applique la loi si
elle litige parce que il y a eu des
mêmes façons
pour voter les résultats actuels me
satisfontainement je crois que c'est le
cas également de mon épouse donc je ne
souhaite pas moi qui dit à nouveau des
élections je pense qu'un troisième
mandat pour Monsieur Biet ce serait
peut-être un peu beaucoup c'est nul le
nouveau maire a été élu il est élu point
on va passer à autre chose
monsieur
qui passe la main si les mauvais joueurs
les mauvais joueurs
nous allons à présent nous pencher sur
cette campagne des élections
départementales dimanche 22 et dimanche
29 mars nous irons voté pour les
conseillers généraux partout en France
la règle a changé puisque dorénavant
c'est un binôme qui va siéger une femme
un homme pour représenter un canton au
nom de la parité il y en a 21 quand on
dans les Yvelines focus dans cette
édition sur 5 d'entre eux qui couvrent
notre secteur tout d'abord le canton de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui comprend
également la commune de Guyancourt le
sortant François de Lignier d'ailleurs
maire de Guyancourt fait équipe avec
Sandrine grandgombe c'est la responsable
du parti socialiste dans le département
on les écoute quand on dit quand est-ce
que vous êtes en campagne moi j'ai
l'impression d'agir pendant tout le
monde a donc je sais pas s'il y a
vraiment une différence en tout cas je
continue à agir je suis auprès des
habitants avec des associations à
répondre à leurs demandes vous savez on
a des tas de sujets il y a des collèges
il y a l'action sociale il y a le
développement universitaire que je suis
aussi particulièrement et donc oui je
continue et la campagne c'est peut-être
le moment où on dit ce qu'on a fait et
on propose
pour l'avenir des engagements précis
du jeu c'est aussi l'enjeu de faire
valoir la pluralité des voix au sein du
conseil départemental et donc il m'a
semblé important de faire partie de ce
combat politique là en tant que
responsable socialiste du département
c'est
je pense nécessaire que on est des
socialistes on est des gens de gauche au
sein de ce département on n'est pas
stupide on sait très bien qu'on ne sera
pas majoritaire mais on tient à ce que
l'opposition existe et face à ce binôme
socialiste le président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
Michel Laugier également maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux un duel de merde
donc il a reçu le soutien de l'UMP
notamment il est associé à Laurence
Trochu élu d'opposition à Guyancourt
dans cette élection me paraît important
que le maire de Montigny est président
de la communauté agglomération de je
suis soit présent dans ce combat puisque
dans les années à venir le travail qui
devrait être fait entre la commune de
l'intercommunalité et le Conseil général
sera de plus en plus important pour
essayer d'avoir des synergies les plus
efficaces possibles et je pense être
l'homme de la situation la droite qui
mise donc beaucoup sur ce canton le
président sortant du conseil général
Pierre Bédier en temps réalisé un Grand
Chelem pour l'UMP il a donc décidé
d'envoyer des candidats de premier plan
en campagne la gauche qui de son côté
apparaît divisé Europe Écologie Les
Verts fait alliance avec le Front de
gauche
ce qu'on voudrait dans cette campagne
c'est faire de la politique un peu
différemment donc on a une équipe qui
est très très jeune on a une équipe de
gens qui ne sont pas déjà mère qui ne
sont pas déjà vice-présidents de la
communauté d'agglo donc vraiment un
renouveau de la politique pour bien
montrer que tous les citoyens tous les
citoyens peuvent s'emparer de la
politique et que c'est pas réservé à
quelques-uns donc notre équipe est
nouvelle renouvelé jeune et donc ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
voudrait avec la participation citoyenne
donc on va organiser des ateliers pour
débattre un peu de ce que les gens
attendent de notre programme voici la
liste complète pour finir des candidats
qui se présentent ici on notera
également une liste Front national le
Front National qui dispose de candidats
dans toutes les Yvelines nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure vous dépendez
du canton de trap si vous habitez
également à la verrière à elancourer
dans ce canton syncliste vous allez les
voir la droite unie la gauche qui se
divise le Front National et une liste
portée par le directeur de l'école
musulmane de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
conseillère générale sortante la divers
Marie elle est associée à Alain Hajjaj
le maire communiste de la verrière mais
si la liste a reçu le soutien des
socialistes elle n'a pas l'investiture
du Front de gauche je rassemblement se
fait dans une volonté d'avoir un maximum
de représentants de la gauche après avec
un parti une étiquette partie sans
étiquette partie c'était pas c'était pas
là l'essentiel l'essentiel c'était la
reconnaissance des qualités de chacun
pour pouvoir porter cette cette fibre
sociale
auprès auprès des gens c'est un
département qui a suffisamment de
richesses pour qu'il s'interroge sur la
répartition de ces richesses et que une
partie de ces richesses puisse être
destinée au développement et à la
réponse aux besoins qui se sont des
besoins sociaux éducatifs ou
d'aménagement ou des besoins écologiques
sur notre canton
c'est inédit mais le communiste à
l'âgeage que vous venez d'entendre
partira donc sans le soutien de son
parti pire une liste Front de Gauche se
présente face à lui menée par Luc
Miserey et Esther Lafitte les
explications du responsable
départemental du Parti communiste sur
cette situation pour le moins
surprenantes on est une organisation
démocratique le Parti communiste
français qui a eu un vote de tous ses
adhérents qui ont décidé que compte tenu
des réalités locales y compris compte
tenu de du bilan Jeannine marie en tant
que sortante de ses prises d'opposition
il était pas possible de se rassembler
avec les socialistes d'ailleurs nos amis
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts ont pris
exactement la même décision donc nous
avons décidé de joindre nos forces pour
présenter quatre candidatures
Alain agence comme c'est son droit le
plus strict de démocratie lui n'était
pas d'accord avec avec cette prise
d'opposition donc il a décidé de prendre
de prendre ses responsabilités de d'être
candidat malgré tout mais il est pas
contre nous et pas plus que nous sommes
contre lui une division de la gauche qui
pourrait donc servir les intérêts de la
liste de l'Union de la Droite menée par
Jean-Michel fourgouse c'est par son
adjointe elle encourt en charge de
l'éducation Anne capill
aujourd'hui
il y a une asphyxie financière de toutes
les communes et dans cette situation la
solution c'est d'aller chercher des
fonds dans d'autres structures comme le
conseiller général ou le conseil général
en attendant que législatives et c'est
vrai que
donc moi j'y vais pour aller chercher de
nouveaux moyens d'un côté Jean-Philippe
Mallet socialiste ancien adjoint au
maire de Bois d'Arcy jusqu'en 2012 de
l'autre Philippe Benassaya le nouveau
maire UMP de Bois-d'Arcy depuis 2014
voici les deux têtes d'affiches de cette
cantonale sur Saint-Cyr-l'École quand on
de si commune qui couvre notamment
Bois-d'Arcy ou encore Villepreux et je
vous propose de les écouter
nous sommes pour des valeurs à l'époque
où la France
a vécu les choses graves profondes
nous voulons nous battre pour ces
valeurs qui ont été portées par le
peuple de France face à une équipe
UMP usée c'est-à-dire de notables locaux
qui sont vraiment sur des conceptions
beaucoup plus étriquées une équipe qui
par ailleurs et peu reluisante le mandat
de conseiller départemental vient en
complément du mandat de mer c'est un
binôme qui est très intéressant parce
que ça permet de d'allier la ville au
département à la rencontre des gens
parler discuter être sur les marchés
faire du porte-à-porte et c'est vraiment
un véritable moment pour discuter avec
les gens c'est pas simplement une
élection un petit peu voilà
administrative c'est une vraie élection
conseil général avec des vraies
compétences qui touchent les gens au
quotidien ça a été une évidence pour
nous de se regrouper force ces élections
départementales
Philippe l'a rappelé et je pense que
c'est vraiment important de de le noter
c'est une élection de proximité il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à mobiliser
les départementales c'est la continuité
de la mairie du local et c'est en ce
sens que c'est important je pense que
les gens se mobilisent pour leur
territoire et on est en train de fois de
plus que sur ce canton également la
gauche est divisée on écoute pour le
front gauche le candidat Jean-Yves
Maximilien il y a pas eu d'alliance avec
le Parti socialiste au premier tour
depuis très longtemps pour ces élections
cantonales que ce soit en 2011 que ce
soit en 2004 il n'y avait pas d'alliance
au premier tour avec le Parti socialiste
aujourd'hui le contexte est un peu
différent entre très différent on va
dire dans la mesure où que ce soit au
niveau national ou que ce soit au niveau
départemental on subit la population
subit une austérité
importante grandissante et l'ensemble de
ces parties ont appelé à une
manifestation le 15 novembre pour une
alternative à l'austérité et donc suite
à ce rassemblement nous avons décidé de
nous rassembler également au niveau
départemental sur le canton de Saint-Cyr
quant aux autres candidats de ce secteur
ils vont s'afficher à présent l'on
retrouve debout la France nouveau parti
et de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan nous allons
y venir plus en détail également dans
quelques minutes
le temps de regarder le canton de
Maurepas canton de pas moins de 16
communes 17 ans de Coignières à
Magny-les-Hameaux en passant par voisin
le Bretonneux il a été totalement
redécoupé ce qui explique la présence de
deux sortants Ismaïla van pour le PS
Yvan de Val pour lui MP deux hommes qui
se présentent à nouveau mes avec leurs
binôme également candidat un bloc
d'hiver à droite un bloc Front de gauche
et un bloc Front national la première
des choses c'est que nous on s'adresse
aux habitants du canton
vous me parlez de vanval certes il est
conseillé général depuis je crois 4 ou 5
mandats tant mieux pour lui mais nous
toute notre problématique n'est pas de
s'adresser avant de Val mais on a un
projet à porter aux habitants et
exclusivement le message est porté vers
eux et on a certes des concurrents entre
guillemets mais c'est pas notre priorité
notre priorité c'est de donner une
réponse au territoire aux habitants en
termes de transport en terme de
solidarité on en a beaucoup parlé tout à
l'heure vu le contexte actuel qui qui
est très dur pour les de ce canton une
association avec le PS à mon avis serait
contre nature aujourd'hui étant donné
que la politique nationale n'est
absolument pas une politique ni
écologique ni sociale ni solidaire et ni
démocratique puisque toutes les lois qui
sont mises en route maintenant le son à
l'insu je dirais des citoyens qu'on
souhaite d'ailleurs ces élections pour
voir construire dans les cantons dans
les villes de notre canton j'irai de
laisser de construire des rassemblements
citoyens à partir j'arrive nos
sensibilités politiques différentes mais
ouvert ça tout le monde et c'est à dire
d'une autre façon dire de repartir du
local pour reconstruire quelque chose
pour que les gens se réapproprient la
politique et qu'ils aient une autre
vision du politique
et puis le cinquième canton que nous
suivons plus particulièrement au cours
de cette campagne c'est celui de plaisir
ici pas moins de 6 binômes candidats un
canton socialiste mais où les loups
sortent les loups sortant n'a pas
souhaité se représenter la gauche est
encore plus divisée comme une liste
écologique n'ayant pas réussi à
s'entendre la mer UMP de plaisir
pourrait donc en profiter on a des
challenges à tenir et puis plaisir est
une ville dynamique et puis ça fait
maintenant deux fois que le canton
échappe au canton de plaisir donc c'est
pas que j'ai la prétention seul de
réussir ça mais enfin je veux dire aussi
cette possibilité de faire un binôme
avec les clés sous bois comme vous le
savez qui est aujourd'hui est
complètement intégré la communauté de
communes et bien me paraissait
intéressante c'est vraiment continuer un
petit peu la politique de proximité
aujourd'hui je suis présent sur la ville
et effectivement le département est un
organisme très important de partenariat
avec la Ville qui nous permet d'aller un
petit peu au-delà de ce que la ville
peut faire tout seul avec avec son
budget au niveau effectivement de tout
ce qui est politique de logement tout ce
qui est effectivement infrastructure
routière c'est vraiment important que
l'on puisse au jour d'aujourd'hui avoir
ce partenariat ce qui m'intéresse
énormément aussi c'est la nouvelle
formule qui associe effectivement
dominos à binômes parité donc ça c'est
très intéressant binôme aussi
d'expérience
pour une seule raison pour laquelle nous
demandons aux électeurs de nous refaire
confiance c'est précisément le nombre
des mandats je suis foncé municipal mais
je ne suis pas membre d'un éducatif
comme on a tout titulaire Frédéric
Evrard nous l'avantage que nous aurons
si nous sommes élus c'est de vraiment
nous
mettre à plein temps à disposition des
habitants de notre canton pour mener
notre notre mandat de conseil général à
plat j'avais vu depuis tout à l'heure le
Front National qui sera donc présent
dans l'intégralité des cantons des
Yvelines dans les 21 quand on voit si
les listes qui ont été déposées en
préfecture le point complet qui est
signé Catherine zolato le Front National
et le premier parti de France sur dans
l'ensemble de la France maintenant ce
que nous voudrions c'est transformer
l'essai et faire en sorte que le Front
national soit aussi le premier parti des
Yvelines
et pour se faire le parti de Marine Le
Pen a mobilisé pour ses départementales
ces candidats élus les plus
emblématiques tels que le maire de
Mantes-la-Ville Cyril note le seul maire
FN d'Île-de-France qui tentera de faire
barrage à pierre-bédier mais également
des conseillers municipaux il était
logique que nous nous présentions
notamment les personnes élues sur la sur
les élections départementales en tant
qu'encium militaire et ancien gendarmes
je suis très sensibilisé par la sécurité
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
véritablement un des points faibles du
gouvernement et les thèmes seront
national parce que forcément je crois
que que les Français s'en attente de
quelque chose de fort qui n'arrive pas
l'immigration chômage insécurité enfin
tous les échecs de l'UMP et du PS depuis
40 ans
d'autres sont plus nouveaux en politique
comme Eric Jégou Estelle et Oliveira
tout juste 19 ans c'est ses valeurs qui
nous ont été transmis à la fac qui m'a
donné l'envie de m'engager aux Front
national liberté qu'elle était
fraternité c'est une notion un petit des
notions qui sont abstraites pour de mon
point de vue on peut pas les retrouver
dans l'actualité ou même dans notre vie
quotidienne j'aimerais un peu apporter
ma pierre à tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui puisque pour moi en fait le
peuple français est un peu lâché la
jeunesse des candidats c'est sur ce
point que veut aussi miser le Front
national pour ses élections à l'image de
Perrine Jugnot adhérentes du Front
national à 16 ans et candidate à 18 ans
seulement je vous montre exemple le
jeune cause passe présenté au Fonds
National l'immigration
le le l'euro
l'insécurité et le chômage je pense très
sincèrement que le Front National est la
seule alternative possible non seulement
au niveau national mais aussi au niveau
local et surtout les problèmes déjà de
travail donc problème de précarité dans
le travail problème de chômage problème
de logement la sécurité un thème
récurrent pour les candidats moi je suis
commerçante j'ai 46 ans et je vois
énormément de misère autour de moi et
clients qui se plaignent les deux tout
de l'insécurité
beaucoup de l'euro aussi beaucoup ont
commencé à étouffer je m'engage un petit
peu plus parce que je voudrais quand
même que que les choses bougent un peu
parce que bon je me reconnais plus
tellement dans moi j'ai 62 ans et je
reconnais plus du tout la France
en 2011 lors des dernières cantonales le
Front national avait présenté des
candidats dans chacun des cantons
renouvelables
le Front National qui durant cette
campagne attaque maintenant frontalement
pierre Bédié le président
UMP du conseil général sortant candidat
sur le canton de Mantes-la-Jolie pour la
formation de Marine Le Pen si la région
de Monte est un foyer de radicalisation
il y a je cite une coïncidence curieuse
avec le soutien de père Bédier à cette
communauté rappelons tout de même que le
Front national présente face à lui sur
ce secteur le nouveau maire de
Mantes-la-Ville issu de Serrant Cyril
note
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan sera lui aussi
présent à l'occasion de ces
départementales dans les Yvelines des
candidats qui s'affichent dans 8 des 21
quand on sur notre secteur nous en
parlions tout à l'heure elles sont les
cantons de Saint-Cyr-l'École et de
plaisir
debout la France anciennement Debout la
République présente des candidats dans 8
cantons Fabien Mettet et pâtissier
aujourd'hui étudiant en histoire et
plaisir roi depuis toujours également
conseillé municipal élu sur la liste de
la mer Joséphine Colmars berger il se
présente pour défendre trois thèmes
politiques une bonne gestion financière
de du département et le bon sens afin de
servir au mieux le bien-être des élus
noirs ce qui m'a donné envie de
rejoindre Debout la République enfin
maintenant debout la France c'est parce
que j'ai enfin j'avais le sentiment que
le pays était mal géré depuis une
quarantaine d'années et que les parties
du gouvernement n'avaient pas réussi à
apporter des solutions adaptées à la
situation et je pense pas non plus que
la situation
viendra des extrêmes
il fera campagne avec Pascal Michard
gérant de société à Plaisir autre binôme
cette fois sur le canton de
Saint-Cyr-l'École s'il vient quand à
l'oupille qui est de toutes les
campagnes politiques et Christophe Pitel
élu conseiller municipal majoritaire à
Villepreux ni système ni extrême lorsque
le gant de campagne nettoyer la
politique on essaie d'avoir des élus
propres nouveaux et qui traînent pas des
casseroles derrière eux parce que après
on est prisonniers soi-même de ses
habitudes et que au conseil général il y
a des c'est le train-train quoi ils sont
entre eux ils font toujours les mêmes
choses les mêmes subventions les mêmes
comportements avoir des subventions qui
soient vraiment utilisées pour pour les
associations et les intérêts des du
canton de Saint-Cyr déjà pour un premier
pour un premier point et surtout
utiliser et pouvoir développer le
département comme il devrait l'être en
dehors du FN qui aujourd'hui est la
seule alternative qui est proposée par
le système contre l'UMP et PS il y a une
autre solution qui a debout la France et
moi j'essaie de mener ce terrain là
c'est candidats mèneront la campagne
avec comme ils disent les moyens du bord
ils ne disposent pas des finances des
grands partis ils feront donc beaucoup
de tractages pour faire connaître le
parti de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
voilà pour ce point complet sur ces
élections départementales et en dehors
de cette campagne ce profil ensuite
celle des régionales Jean-Paul Huchon
qui ont en se présenter pour un
quatrième mandat en Île-de-France vient
de recevoir le soutien de 85 élus
francilien il publie une tribune pour le
soutenir donc face à une concurrence de
plus en plus affichée de sa première
vice-présidente Marie-Pierre delagonerie
cette dernière qui bénéficie de l'appui
d'un appui de poids celui d'Ann Hidalgo
la maire de Paris
prochain numéro du 7 8 politique mardi
prochain je vous rappelle aussi que nous
commencerons ce jour-là le 3 mars donc
notre série de débats avec les candidats
au départemental ce sera à 19h premier
débat avec les candidats du canton de
Trappes pour tout revoir pour tout
savoir sur cette campagne rendez-vous
aussi sur notre site Internet grâce au
Replay et puis chaque soir de la semaine
18h 19h 22h30 ainsi que minuit pour le
journal très bonne soirée